avec nous il est
20h42 on est en direct touche pas mon
poste merci d'être avec nous et on va
passer à la alors à Stéphan Plazza alors
je m'en suis jamais caché j'aime
beaucoup Stéphan Plazza et je l'ai
toujours dit ici donc voilà je bien sûr
je suis je suis triste de tout ce qu'on
dit sur lui actuellement j'attends bien
entendu que la justice fasse son travail
voilà et bien sûr je suis triste si il y
a des victimes
euh si pour les victimes présumé si il y
a eu bien sûr ce qu' ce qu'ell décrivent
mais c'est vrai que voilà je men suis
jamais caché ici j'aime beaucoup
l'animateur j'aime beaucoup l'homme et
c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours été en
tout cas avec nous toujours à nos côtés
qui a toujours été là donc c'est vrai
que on est triste euh pour les victimes
s'il y en a on est triste pour Stéphan
Plaza si voilà on a envie que la justice
fasse son travail au plus vite et on on
fait confiance bien sûr à la justice et
c'est vrai que tous les jours euh voilà
en ce moment il y a des nouvelles choses
qui sortent euh sur Stéphane Plaza
aujourd'hui euh il est accusé de
violence conjugal sur trois anciennes
compagnes donc ça deux d'entre elles ont
décidé de porter plainte et aujourd'hui
de nouvelles révélations sortent de la
presse il aurait aussi des comportements
au travail alors c'était dans Libération
euh je vais vous lire l'article parce
que autant les violences ça je donne pas
mon avis et je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé et je laisse la justice faire son
travail et bien entendu euh on croit les
victimes c'est la première chose qu'on
qu'on doit faire et qu'il faut faire on
croit les victimes et après on laisse la
la justice faire son travail après sur
les problèmes de comportement au travail
alors je vais vous dire ça des articles
j'en ai eu j'en ai vu des des millions
des milliers sur moi il y en a eu des
des des des ah je peux vous dire des
pelletés je vous dis on peut dire on
peut faire dire et dire n'importe quoi
sur un inanimateur et il est colérique
et il dit c et il dit ça je ve vous dire
moi aussi hein je peux aller chercher
des anciens collaborateurs à moi et je
pense que c'est ce qu'ils vont faire
d'ailleurs dans tous les reportages qui
se préparent sur moi he et qui vont dire
bah oui non il a fait c il a fait ça il
a fait je vous dis donc ça tout le monde
peut le faire même vous qui n regardez
je suis sûr que vous avez des anciens
collègues à vous voilà même toi voilà
des clients qui disent ilable insortable
Rais on va faire un petit rcap et vous
allez voir les nouveaux ce qui est
reproché à Stéphane Plazza on va en
parler bien sûr avec Miriam Palomba
toujours bien sûr spécialiste des raser
voilà c'est ce qu'on c'est
rasamus
depuis plusieurs jours un animateur d'M6
est au cœur d'une lourde affaire Stéphan
Plazza qui est accusé de violence
conjugale sur trois anciennes compagne
au total ce sont donc trois femmes qui
accusent Stéphane Plazza de violence
physique et verbale qui de son côté ni
ses accusations il lui aurait mis le
bras au niveau de la gorge elle aurait
eu un arrachement une luxation des
articulations de doigts mais alors que
la chaîne avait ces derniers jours fait
parler d'elle en continuant à mettre à
l'antenne l'animateur et à diffuser un
documentaire sur lui plazard agresseur
l'affaire connaît aujourd'hui des
rebondissements avec le dépôt de deux
plaintes et avec de nouveaux témoignages
contre le présentateur affire Stéphane
Plazza de plaines pour violence
conjugale comportement toxique au
travail menace de licenciement abusif
toutes les information ce soir dans
TPMP voilà donc on va parler de
l'affaire Stéphan Plaz avec
ramusamus la spécialiste de
RAM palombaam est déjà vous pouvez nous
rappeler ce qui reprochait à Stéphane
Plazza alors je sais pas si vous
souvenez dans mdiap il y a trois jeunes
femmes qui ont témoigné au cours d'un
d'un long article où elle dénonce en
fait des humiliations des
violences des menaces de mort que leur
aurait prodigué Stéphane Plazza d'accord
alors ça CIT une chose et alors il y a
deux plaintes de déposer donc on va voir
la justi va faire son travail mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est quoi alors
en fait là ce qui est ce qui est nouveau
c'est que les les trois jeunes femmes
ont été en entendu du 13 au 23 octobre
dernier dans un commissariat parisien
selon selon media part et que donc elles
ontitétiré leurs leurs accusations et
suite à des des heures d'audition hein
parce que ça a duré quand même très
longtemps deux d'entre elles ont porté
plainte pour violence par conjoint
contre Stéphane Plazza et la troisième
se réserve encore le droit de de porter
plainte ou pas d'accord alors donc
Stéphane Plazza on va rappeler donc
l'affaire donc est-ce que vous pouvez
rappeler ce qui lui a été dit ce qui ce
qui été dit et cetera on va rappeler les
révélations concernant le comportement
de Stéphane Plaza au travail et je
redonnerai mon avis là-dessus et vous
savez ce que j'en pense jeonner quand
même alors alors donc il y avait une
première he les noms ont échangé pour
pour préserver l'anonymat des jeunes
femmes donc il y a une première jeune
femme qui qu'on nommera Jade qui
l'accuse donc de lui avoir cassé un
doigt avec un désossement hceux de
l'avoir euh attrapé par par le coup et
de lui avoir mis le bras comme ça elle
s'est senti menacé étranglé et puis elle
l'accuse aussi dans des faits qui sont
un peu plus un peu plus vieux qui datent
de 201 de lui avoir donné un violent
coup à l'épaule voilà donc il a a ce
premier témoignage il y en a une
deuxième qui raconte que en fait
Stéphane Plazza l'a menacé de mort euh
la menace parce qu'il aurait appris que
elle le trompait donc donc donc voilà et
et du coup il l'aurait lors de de de de
relation enfin lors d'une dispute mordue
à plusieurs reprises sur la jambe et ce
qu'on apprend d'ailleurs de nouveau dans
dans cette enquête de médiap mais c'est
donc là en ce moment tout le monde
mort c'est vra ouais ou moi j'étais pas
là mais bon ce qu'on apprend ce qui
assez drôle aussi hein ce qu'on apprend
c'est que cette cette jeune femme
explique que si Stéphane Plaza croyait
qu'il l'a trompé c'est parce qu'il
s'était fait monter la tête par une
voyante qui avait vu dans dans les
cartes que elle le trompait donc ça
l'aurait mis d'une colère noire et il
l'aurait menacé en disant je te préviens
si tu me trompes je te tue voilà et il y
a une trisè mais oui mais c'est après on
va faire on va laisser la justice faire
son travail bien entendu non mais moi je
voilà je vous relate les fait mais on
arrête tous les maris qui ont dit ça à
leurs femmes dans une ça va faire
beaucoup de gens com on le dit hein les
FEM voilà après après là-dessus on peut
pas juger on laissera la justice faire
son travail après on va revenir sur
l'article d'aujourd'hui ma ma
mimi et sinon il y en a une troisème qui
qui rappelle elle est partie en voyage
en voyage avec lui à à Vienne je crois
et
queon avec avec qui avec François
fman non ils ont pas dansé la valse mais
bon bref et et du coup lors de lors de
ce voyage pareil elle lui aurait dit bah
je sais que tu me trompes que tu as
plusieurs relations à la fois et
Stéphane Plaza se serait mis très en
colère lors du dîner qu'il faisait au
restaurant et aurait même pointé sa
fourchette vers elle très menaçant
franchement ouais mais vraiment je sais
que pens oui oui peut-être dire aussi
que les victimes présumées vont être
examiné par des experts et donner la
réaction de l'avocat de Stéphane Plaz
pour l'instant il faut toujours croir
les
victimes faut laisser faire
l'enquête y a des expertises médicau qui
vont dire quelles sont les répercussions
aujourd'hui de ce qui s pe-être passé
voir combien de jours d' tt es ont eu
parce que c'est ce qui détermine les
peines éventuelles donc c'est très
sérieux voilà et il y a aussi beaucoup
de collaborateurs qui vont être entendus
par par les aut moi j'attends de voir
quelles sont vraiment les les violences
et cetera parce que s'il y a eu violence
bien sûr c'est extrêmement grave et là
forcément on attend de savoir ce que va
dire la justice
oui dans dans certains cas comme ça
quand il y a des violences psychologique
des comportements toxiques au travail
menace de licenciement abusif souvent et
en plus c'est un be trit à la mode on
peut dire que que ce sont peut-être des
profils de pervers narcissiques et je
pense que ça c'est pas des gens qui
devraient être mis sur le le plan de la
justice mais plus sur du médical et je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
personnes qui devrai être soumis à de
non à des à des psychologues et la
société irait vraiment mieux parce qu'on
a une recrud desence de ces personnagesl
souvent qui ont du pouvoir et qui font
des aberérations jusqu'à perdre parfois
leur job parce que la justice et le côté
psychologique
sontusemuse là il y avait le cassage il
y avait il y avait les doigtsou maiselà
de ça a tout le
reste quand ça devient s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît quand c'est bon quand ça
devient violent là on a pas besoin de
médecin on a besoin de la justice et les
coups c'est pas forcément les coups
portés hein c'est aussi des coups quand
quelqu par le truc là
c'est on va parler de l'article qui est
sorti aujourd'hui concernant le
comportement de Stéphan pazza au travail
alors ça je vous l'ai dit le
professionnel pourexactement pour ce que
vient de dire Delphine et cetera ça s'il
y a eu violence et cetera ça bien sûr
c'est extrêmement grave et la justice
fera son travail là là-dessus je
j'attends ce que de voir ce que vous
allez me dire et un article sur Stéphan
Plazza parce que ça y est maintenant ils
sont sur ses côtes hein donc des
révélations concernant le comportement
de Stéphan Plazza au travail moi je
voudrais dire déjà un truc euh donc
c'est libération oui c'est libération
qui a fait une enquête d' Mo ils en ont
fait ils en ont fait plein des enquêtes
aussi sur moi oui sur moi aussi mais je
vous dire je vous dire ils on ils font
des enquêtes sur moi toutes les semaines
même dans cet article ils ont parlé de
moi d'ailleurs libération sur Stéphan
pad j'ai même pas compris pour un truc
qu'on en avait parlé dans TPM et ca donc
voilà donc il parle tout le temps de moi
libération voilà donc on va donner une
tribune à Libération ce soir qui n'ont
jamais puisque ils sont très Pelus donc
demain vous verrez dans dans une semaine
ils font un article sur moi c'est ce
qu'ils font à chaque fois chaque fois
que je les tacle derrière ils font un
article sur moi pour dire que j'ai fait
une fake news ou un truc comme ça voilà
donc libération voilà donc je je je
prononce votre nom c'est déjà bien pour
vous c'est vrai que ça vous faire encore
des gens qui vont savoir que vous
existez parce que on est très peu à le
savoir maintenant voilà donc donc il
pourrait faire article sur moi dans une
semaine de semaines et ce qui est
incroyable c'est que vous C dans
l'article d'ailleurs mais je sais je
viens de le dire siéta
là merci les journalistes de Libération
plus ils sont incroyables la dernière
fois il me disent on fait un portrait
sur quelqu'un on aimerait bien vous
avoir au téléphone mais j'ai dit mais
les mecs ils sont sans gêes en fait
c'est incroyable c'est les gars ils
mettent ils mettent des taquets toutes
les semaines mais ils veulent que quand
même je leur parle au téléphone je vais
prendre une demi-heure de mon temps al
pourêre ou alors je pouris être au padle
pour parler à un journaliste de
Libération dont je me fous totalement
pour lui permettre de faire son article
écoutez libération je sais pas c'est lu
par 30000 personnes donc voilà ce soir
on n jamais dit autant leur nom donc ils
ont fait un article sur Stéphan Plaza
puisqu'ils se disent peut-être que
Stéphan Plaza ça marche donc il était en
une et cetera ils sont dit B tu sais
quoi on va faire de l'audience avec
Stéphan Plaza on va peut-être vendre
avec Stéphan Plaza donc ils ont réussi
leur coup puisque même nous on en parle
ce soir donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit
sur Stéphan Plazza libération et on va
voir encore ce ce ce ce qu'ils ont dit
et je je je Mo je les porte pas dans mon
cœur je les porte pas dans mon cœur
libération mais pour pour être très
clair ils ont quand même fait une
enquête oui oui mais moi aussi je peux
faire des enquêtesz vous inquiétez pas n
on fait enquête complémentaire aussi
vous allez voir je vais faire une
enquête sur libération vous allez voir
ça va être rigolo je pense donc en fait
ils ont ils ont interrogé plusieurs
collaborateurs alors déjà ce qu'ils
disent c'est toujours anonyme he
témoignage anonyme il y a pas un gars
qu'on connaît ni personne c'est que des
témoignages anonymes donc voilà B comme
déjà donc voilà c'est un gars qui l'a vu
passer peut-être une fois il a vu manger
un pe au chocolat donc le témoignage
anonyme qui dit s'il apprend que je vous
ai parlé je crains pour ma vie il est
capable de me faire du mal d'accord oui
Stéphan Plazza est un tueur à gage
mainant St PL c'est le Parin ils font
passer tout le monde pour le Parin donc
Stéphan
Plaz non mais c'est ça tu parles dans
l'bay donc Stéphan Plazza il va mettre
un contrat sur lui stéan Plazza il a des
agences immobilières non mais c'est ça
ouais et puis la forêt aussi les G
immobiliers aussi vous dites vous prenez
pas un appart il va vous mettre un
contrat bon déjà ça il le décrivent tous
alors je vais le faire moi-même parce
que ça fout un homme habité par le
sentiment de tout puissance exubérant
extravagant complètement achité du bocal
et faisant beaucoup de bruit donc voilà
l'article faisant beaucoup de bruit
qu'est-ce qu'il y a làdedans il écrit un
homme habité par le sentiment de toute
puuissance écoutez siil est il est bien
dans sa peau il serait sûr de lui et se
sentirait intouchable wouh waouh [__]
ah ouais les révélations Stéphan ils se
sont intouchables fort il forcerait tout
le monde à faire des selfies avec lui
pour faire croire que les gens se jette
sur lui non mais c'est incroyable ça non
mais genre Stéphan Plazza il est dans la
rue donc fait tu veux pas faire un avec
moi s'il te plaît c'est non mais les
gars c'est c'est c'est c'est quoi c'est
une farce sans rigoler les mecs soyez
sérieux excusez-moi les gars oh vous
êtes encore vous existez enc pas mal
excusez-moi là vous vous vous faites du
mal c'est et répéter constamment qu'il
est l'animateur préféré des Français
qu'il est le numéro 1 bah écoutez s'il
le dit voilà il a raison c'est vrai que
c'est un des animateurs préférés des
français il se un témoignage anonyme non
mais je lire tout l'article de
Libération je vou rester avec nous 2055
c'est une énorme rigolade il se prend
pour le roi de l'immobilier le roi de M6
le roi de France un témoignage anonyme
il y a pas un mec qui a pas peur de
Plaza qui veut donner son
nom il menacerait quotidiennement ses
employés déclarant que S se ve s'il ne
faisait pas ce qu'il demandait il serait
viré l'un de ses excollaborateurs
déclare à ce sujet tous ceux qui bossent
pour lui vont un jour être punis à la
moindre contrariété comme un retard par
exemple qu'on soit photographe
maquilleuse ou régisseur on peut-être éc
écarté d'un tournage un jour ou plus il
instaurerait un climat de peur selon ses
collaborateurs il faut être parti pour
parler sinon ce n'est pas possible j'ai
rien compris d'accord c'est vrai il êt
parti pour parler oui il faut être parti
il faut avoir quitté l'endroit où il
bosse avec lui pour pour voilà pour
partir c'est ça l'article c'est ça il y
a d'autres choses euh oui enfin il parle
d' d'un management toxique il parle
aussi d'une ambiance hyp sexualisé sur
les plateaux et puis il parle également
du gros problème d'après eux d'alcool de
Stéphane Plaza qui d'ailleurs a lui-même
dit hein qu'il avait un alcool Mondin et
donc eux ils racontent que c'est pire
que que ça puisque en fait il fallait
ravitailler selon leur propos tous les
jours la loge en vodka en 20in et cetera
et que les gens étaient contents même de
lui bourrer comme de lui bourrer
excusez-moi l'expression la la la
tronche parce que du coup ça leur
permettait d'avoir un espèce d'ascendant
sur bien sûr non mais écoutez
franchement moi les les un témoignages
anonyme a dit même un mec qui a lui qui
a travaillé avec lui il y a 10 ans qui
dit il a fait c il a fait ça moi écoutez
moi ça franchement l'artile de
libération pour moi je vais prendre ce
soir et vous savez ce que je vais faire
avec on est dans le linchage médiatique
tout ce qui lui est reproché dans cet
article n'est pas répréhensible par la
justice terrible là où le Procé jour est
dégueulasse c'est que souvent les gens
ne lisent pas les articles donc les gens
vont voir stéan Plaz en Une de lib on
dir donc Plazza c'est chaud et on s'est
tous dit ça en fait on a tous reçu les
pou les infos les articles les tweets
qui sortent on s'est dit assez chaud et
quand on se penche je ne dis pas que
certains faits ne sont pas graves mais
excusez-moi la majorité des choses qui
sont décrites il y a rien du tout quand
on dit Stéphan Plaz c'est devenu Tony
Montana mais voilà c'est bon merci et il
faut ajouter le fait que moi je je suis
stupéfait par le fait que tout ça sorte
aujourd'hui alors que Stéphan bien sûr
con depuis combien de temps fait combien
de temps qu'il fait de la télé 10 ans 15
ans 20
ans att excuse il a une agrégation de
papier on vaprendre encore d'autres
quand même très étrange je comprends
libération et bravo libération ils
veulent exister ils vend ils vendent pas
les pauvres je parlerai d'ux et et je
sais qu'ils vont faire un article sur
moi certainement dans 2 jours dans 3
jours dans une semaine dans un mois a le
marchand quand même qui s'est
exprimé qu' l'a défendu dans Dans le
Paris Match qui va sortir demain donc où
explique que oui il peut il a il s'est
il s'est mal peut-être mal comporté avec
ses femmes parce que vous savez tous que
cararille l mararchand est la grande
confidente de de Stéphane
Plazza mais qu'elle ne connaît pas
Stéphane Plazza enfin elle l'a jamais vu
violent et puis elle rappelle certain
fait ça prouve qu'elle est au courant
quand même de l'histoire que la fameuse
jade voilà était son assistante il lui a
offert un poste d'assistante sur sur sur
sur ses émissions et que il lui aurait
payé son loyer de 1400 € pendant pendant
4 ans alors même qu'il n'était plus
ensembleelle prend vraiment sa défense
merci merci mirriam on en reparlera
Stéphane Pasard on en parle tous les
jours là il est il est tard il est 20h59
on doit passer à l'autre sujet on va
passer au témoins du jour et vous allez
voir cette histoire folle qui a commencé
le 7 septembre ce soir là un chien a
attaqué gravement blessé un bébé de 2
mois dans sa poussette alors qu'il
rentrait chez lui accompagné de